no I think some of what we can
anticipate is already happening that I
mean you have to you have to think in
terms of the Strega nomics strata and
the American population poor people and
working people are already suffering
they've they're already cutting back I
read stories every day in the new york
times in the Wall Street Journal of
working people were having a very hard
time the trucking industry farmers
working people who have long commutes
have to cut back on everything in their
life just to pay for gas now that will
work itself up from the working people
blue-collar people and farmers and and
artisans who drive long distances to the
middle class will start suffering and
work its way higher and higher all of us
will start suffering in various ways I
think summer vacations are going to be
very problematic air air travel will
become much more costly so in all kinds
of ways we will start experiencing all
kinds of hardships in our lives small
businesses will have to will shut down
resorts will shut down or at all and
this will then ripple out across the
economy and and I think the recession
that we're already experiencing will go
deeper and more severe
you